all right so jumping right in um what
was it that Drew you to the brother's
son first of all I'd say it was a story
so I think there was a tremendous amount
of resonance with the theme um you know
the idea of family is really important
in our story and I myself am very close
to my family I I love my parents I love
my siblings so being able to tell a
story that touched on that was really
exciting to me and second um the fact
that the story matches so closely to my
own Blended upbringing I grew up in
Taiwan and Los Angeles that's exactly
where a show is set so anytime I come
across something that touches on
shooting in Taiwan or La I'm I'm I
immediately get giddy um also the the
character of Charles
was probably you know as an actor you're
lucky if you get three to four auditions
that resonate with you each year and out
of the hundreds of auditions that I've
been on
this one this role of Charles by far
resonated with me the most and was the
one that I was most excited for and I
think it was because um well one of my
favorite actors Tom Hardy and I think
what he does the best is he plays these
characters that are menacing and and
brutal and ruthless but also have a
vulnerable side and that's what I find
most interesting to watch as well so I
felt like I had an opportunity to
attempt to do something like that with
this character and and also like this
when I read this character and I read
the sides I was like I don't know what
it is when I first read it I didn't know
what it was but I knew that I knew that
that was me I knew that I could play
that character and I knew that I was
Charles and so in a way it gave me a
sense of peace through the audition
process I was I was so certain of how I
wanted to do it because I think part of
what I did was give the performance that
I think I I would want to watch and not
what I think the creatives wanted to see
um so so all all of that made this
project just so tremendously special to
to be a part of so you said that you saw
like you kind of resonated with Charles
and you saw kind of that commonality
there but I'm curious in kind of
bringing him to life whether you like
like what parts of yourself you kind of
worked into him after the fact like as
you were playing him totally um in the
process of of creating this character
even though I'm so different from him I
don't kill people on a regular basis
um I thought it was just kind of a
radical idea to be myself and to bring
myself to this role because that way
there's nothing to hide behind if people
like it or they don't that's me they're
watching so that was probably the first
choice and that really open the door to
Bringing In My Own experiences my own
background um I used them as jumping off
points so I I a big part of my process
was I guess remembering the moments that
I've shared with my father or my mother
or my brothers and how all those moments
have have shaped me into the person that
I am today like the Happy moments the
the sad moments the all all of my
memories I try to incorporate as jumping
off points because those things then
helped Inspire the the character's
imaginary background and the things that
I would have felt as Charles um and then
myself as well I'm I'm a huge fan of
martial arts so I started training in
Muay Thai about 10 years ago and I've
been doing Jiu-Jitsu pretty intensely
for the last four years I just got my
blue Bel and I did a competition earlier
this year um so those things were also
part of crafting the character um there
was something about being in a stunt
training environment that helped
me mold into the physicality that I
wanted to have for Charles uh in terms
of like I wanted there to be a weight to
his walk like ready to fight at any
moment and also in terms of adjusting
his posture as well so all of those
things were were just so much fun to
work into and and um I'm really I I love
I love the character of Charles and I'm
I'm really grateful that I had the
opportunity to play him so you talked
kind of about Charles having that you
know that toughness and that
vulnerability at the same time and I
think that really speaks to the whole
show because there is a lot of violence
but there is like family the
vulnerability but there's also like you
know there's comedy with Charles there's
like a they won't they romance there all
of that so I guess my question is for
you as a performer like what is your
trick way to like kind of strike the
balance between all of those things
going on that's a great
question I think for me it always starts
with the story I think once I've
immersed myself deeply enough in the
story I know how my character will
respond and I know how he feels and I'm
feeling those things as they're
happening um so that's the first thing I
think is like the the the committed
preparation and research and immersion
into the story and the role and then
also is when Sparks of inspiration or
maybe like things that are more just and
come out I just run with it because I
think those are the moments that they
may or may not work they might be a
little risky they might be a little
messy but I think those are the moments
where I know I'm truly present and I'm
out of my head and I'm just trusting
whatever happens happens so in terms the
humor like there moments where I'm like
oh I don't know if Charles would do that
but let's just do it anyway so like
there's a moment where we're both
getting scolded and I think I go like
behind my mom's back and like that's
something that I've done with my
siblings as well like to tease them so
um yeah I'd say incorporating one is
immersing myself deeply into the story
and then just incorporating and
experiencing whatever it is that happens
on the day I have to ask you know
working on the show your mom is played
by the legendary Michelle y
what is that like working with with such
a screen Legend it was definitely
intimidating at first but it I overcame
that very quickly only because she is
the coolest gal she is so down to earth
she she is so in command of her ability
that she's able to almost glide through
set and deliver right away and I I I
learned a lot from her I learned that
you can be this
force of of of character and this force
of acting it was like watching a a
master class every day but that you
could also be just a downto earth chill
warm person I remember like some of my
Fondest Memories is when we'd hang out
her her place and crack open a bottle of
wine and like snack and just shoot the
like she's she is Oscar winner
Michelle yo but she's also just my
friend Michelle also to your your
Dynamic with um Sam who plays Bruce um
as an older sibling is very authentic to
The Sibling relationship so kind of how
did the two of you forge that that
brotherly bond in prepping for this yeah
so I myself am the oldest sibling of
four kids so that banter and that like
big brother it comes it it's so natural
to me and it's very natural for Sam as
well um
a funny story is actually when I was
going into our final call back Bruce in
the script was described as like you
know the scrawny a little bit on the
nerdier side and I walk in and I see him
and he's this big tall boy and I was
like oh my God he's huge but luckily it
worked out for us um we developed that
just through just through time and being
in the trenches together and bonding
over shared humor and and our love for
this show and our characters and and uh
we screw around with each other unset
just to keep things light like we tease
each other or like you know play like
very small harmless pranks or like take
really ugly photos of each other so it
was um it was a lot of fun working with
him so the authentic sibling experience
yeah I definitely see him as my little
brother so what was your biggest
challenge then in in making the show in
prepping and filming and at any stage
that is that was a great question um
apart from the obvious answer which
included some like the bigger fight I
don't know if you've seen the whole
thing I've seen the whole thing oh well
thank you I'm really glad you have um
physically the biggest challenge
challenges were the Golf Scene but also
the giant fight in episode one cuz that
was actually my first two days on set
and my first days ever of TV work but
luckily I had a a wonderful dance
partner in Nate undra it's like 6'8 6'9
he's like thanos's stunt double he can
kick above his head he's more flexible
to me but so he shephered me through the
whole process and I'm really grateful
that I I got to have such a wonderful
partner for that that first challenging
day um but in terms of the acting I
think the biggest challenge for me was
um letting go of the idea of of should
or what I think a scene should be like
what would make a good scene because I
think that puts my heads space in the
wrong it puts my heads space in the
wrong focus and I think for me it was
just reminding myself to trust that the
hard work was done that I was Charles
and that all I need to do was focus on
my scene partner and and just let
whatever come out come out and just
trust that it was going to be good no
matter what so I I think I was able to
let go for most of it so kind of letting
Instinct letting letting it happen and
really the fundamentals of what good
acting is not trying to like say a line
a certain way or or deliver a look a
certain way but just be there and look
at the person and and and receive what
they're giving and then give back as
authentically as possible and then as I
wrap up what is it that you are
especially looking forward to people
seeing be it like a theme or a certain
episode a certain sequence what are you
most excited for people to see I'm most
excited for people to see my real life
mother in the show so I don't know if
you know but my mom is one of the Majong
aunties in episode three I get to share
a scene with Michelle who plays my mom
and my real life mom and I think that by
far is the most special thing to me of
this entire process even though it was
so special in so many different ways
because my mom when she was younger she
also had dreams of being an actor and I
helped her tape this audition I coached
her through it I got to one be the one
that made the call to be like hey you
got the part and you know I remember we
drove to set in the morning my mom my
mom's based in Taiwan but she was
staying with me at the time um we pulled
up to set and I showed her a trailer
which had her name on it and she got to
go into hair and makeup and get pampered
and then on set she had her own chair
that someone was super sweet they wrote
Justin's mom on it um and and then as
you know I remember watching her as
she's bonding with the other majang
aunties they're like giggling and like
being like my God this is so cool like I
I could just see her like smiling ear to
ear the whole time and like the fact
that I got to play a part in bringing my
mom that Joy was it it still makes me
emotional now and I'm I'm I'm so
grateful that I got to share that with
her that's so sweet and I think that's
the perfect note to wrap this up on
thank you so so much the show was great
thank you thanks for watching all of but
I'm glad you I'm glad you did I'm
excited to share it with my own mom
because she loves likeing action like
that is her thing so I'm very excited
about that thank you so much thank you
it's very nice to meeting
you